clark county school district teachers
are a little concerned tonight that
another wave of resignations is going to
come in the new year yeah they say
unsolved health insurance issues low pay
and a very lean staff have pushed many
teachers to just leave kate houston digs
into the number of vacancies and how
it's impacting morale
i'm seeing people that i know are
excellent educators either leaving have
already left or they're planning their
exit right now some teachers in the
clark county school district are more
than fed up we need to be proactively
trying to retain our good teachers and
no one will do anything vicki cordell
says any more shortages could push
schools backwards if they don't have
enough staff members to safely open a
site they're going to have to make
decisions like maybe go to distance
learning until they have enough there
are currently 811 teacher vacancies in
september 8 news now reported 750. we're
going to have a mass exodus after winter
break and the district thinks we have
vacancies now
come january we're really going to be in
trouble kristin nygro says teachers are
stretched thin covering multiple classes
and substitute shortages are forcing
teachers to give up prep periods to help
out we're talking about working together
again we need to sit down or not we
leadership needs to sit down and discuss
what they're going to do about this
problem despite frustrations credel says
there's still time to do something about
it they have a last straw they have a
point where that's it i'm done not
everybody's at that point yet before we
lose more people the district should be
doing something to retain the teachers
they have right now kate houston live
local now